hello learners welcome to this new video
by simply learn
is your website not ranking as you
thought it would
are there too many competitions out
there
is it getting difficult to capture
relevant audiences
are the solutions suggested too
expensive
do not worry in this video you will get
easy solutions to all your questions as
we have come up with the list of top 10
seo tools that anyone can use and the
best part is you need not to spend a
single penny on these tools
yes you heard it right they are free of
cost and are very useful for anyone who
wants to start an online business
or struggling to improve reach so let's
jump right into the list
but before we do
kindly subscribe to our channel simply
learn and hit the bell icon to never
miss on such interesting and useful
videos
to carry out best seo practices the
first free tool on our list is the
keyword planner
keyword planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by google
proper keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result pages
the keyword planner will help to
discover new keywords
estimate monthly searches a keyword has
get the cost of ads for the keyword
you're looking for
and help to organize keywords
let's understand how to use google
keyword planner
open your adwords account
now
go to the tools section and select
keyword planner
now you can either add a keyword to get
new insights or upload a csv file to get
search volumes of already known keywords
let's see how it works
click on discover new
keywords from here you can change the
location
enter the keyphrase for which you need
keyword insights
click on get results
here you can see all the keyword ideas
related to your keyword phrase
now to get the search volumes of already
known keywords go to the keyword planner
and click on get search volume and
forecast
now upload your csv file from here
here you will get search volumes for all
the keywords
other similar tools with free trials
include
keyword tool dot io
and keyword generator by rfs
to know trending ideas you can use
google trends whereas to get title ideas
you can use the answer the public tool
which is free
now let's see the next tool in the
bucket
google search console
google search console is a free
webmaster tool provided by google
it is important to timely monitor your
website and make it error free
this is where google search console
comes into the picture
it helps businesses to monitor and
maintain their website's presence in
google search results
some features of google search console
includes
getting confirmation that google search
engine can crawl your website
fix the problems in page indexing
sends pages for
re-indexing can view google search
traffic data
records the number of times your website
appears in the search results
records the search queries for which
website appears in the search result
shows the list of sites linking to you
and many more
let's now understand how to use google
search console
here the total impressions suggest that
number of times your website appears in
the google search results
whereas the total clicks suggest that
number of times your website is clicked
from the google search result page
from the coverage section
you will get to know all the errors
occurred during the crawling
we recommend you to try your hands on
tools like bing webmaster tool
and rfs which is free for website owners
next up we have the yoast seo plugin
yoast seo plugin helps in improving your
search results ranking
it also free as well as a paid version
as a beginner you can quickly check the
free version
it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out seo analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at seo plugin
from here you can add seo title
from here you can edit the slug slug is
the part of url you can add the
necessary keyword here
in the meta description section you can
add the meta description
which all together looks like this
well this part
is your slug the keyword you want to add
in your page should be added in the
focus key phrase section
the seo analysis section
shows the seo improvements in your
content
now moving towards the readability
analysis
readability analysis shows improvement
in the textual content of the page
if both the indicators are green
then your seo and readability both are
good to go
for yoast seo we have covered the
significant features and now we will
understand one of the essential seo
tools
google analytics
website tracking plays an important role
in seo it helps in understanding the
user behavior on your website
google analytics is an analytics tool
used for tracking a website
the standard version of google analytics
is free
we can integrate google analytics with
google ads
the main features of google analytics
include tracking session duration of
users
pages per session
and tracking website traffic and bounce
rate of users
let's take a quick tour of google
analytics
here you can see reports of users for
last 7 days
now go to the reports section in the
dashboard
you can reset the time span to get the
desired data from here
go to retention
where you can see the number of new
users and the number of returning users
to your website
to know the data on monetization
go to the monetization section
here you can see the monetization data
for the selected time span
we will understand google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail
moving ahead with the next tune which is
small seo tools pulsarism checker
duplicate content is hated by search
engines
if not taken seriously this could hurt
your search rankings
the plagiarism checker detects duplicate
data in your content and shows its
source
you need to open this plagiarism checker
here you can add your content manually
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a verification
and click on check plagiarism
and here we get the results the content
is hundred percent unique
in case if we get any duplicate content
we can check the sources from here
as our content is unique we are not
getting any results here
in case if you don't want to enter your
content manually you can upload document
file from here
note that this checker checks for the
top thousand words of your content so in
case of lengthy content you can break
the content and then check for its
uniqueness
in case you don't want to purchase the
pro version
moreover you can also add a page url to
check the uniqueness of the content the
page has over here
and follow the same process by clicking
on the check plagiarism button
the plagiarism checker by grammarly is
also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content
the next tool that we have in our bucket
is the page speed insights
as per the data provided by google the
bounce rate increases to 32 percent as
the page load speed increases from 1 to
3 seconds
page speed insights is the paid speed
check tool
page speed insights is used to test the
speed of a web page and it is a free
service offered by google developers
results of paid speed insights show what
real users are experiencing about your
page on mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to
page speed insights and select the url
of the website for which you want to
undergo the check
enter the url and click on analyze
button
now choose whether you wish to undergo a
check for mobile or desktop device here
i'll select a desktop device
just in few seconds you will get the
required results
another tool that we can use is
tools.pingdom.com
which has free as well as paid versions
moving forward to the next magic tool
which is
sem rush
to grow your business it is essential to
keep an eye on what your competitors are
doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitor
analysis sem rush is the competitor
analysis tool
that gives a complete walkthrough to
competitors data like keywords
backlinks
top performing content
campaigns
etc
it has free as well as paid versions you
can access free trials by simply signing
up on
semrush.com
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
login to your sem rush account
here enter the url of your competitor
here you can choose a geographical
location
for which the analysis is to be
performed
by adding url you get all the competitor
data
here i have added sem rush as a
competitor so we are getting so many
details of sem rush
the organic keywords the organic traffic
paid keywords paid traffic referral
domains and authority score
we can add a competitor as well from
here
now here you can see the data of both
sem rush and refs
other than sem rush
you can use spyfu
which has some free daily trials now let
me tell you about an excellent auditing
tool
which is screaming frog
dear learners it is essential to know
how your website is performing and for
this you need to carry out frequent
website audits
streaming frog is a website auditing
tool that works similar to web crawlers
it has free as well as paid versions
some features of free version include
finding broken links errors and
redirects
analyzing page title and metadata
href lang attributes auditing finding
duplicate content etc with a crawl limit
of 500 urls
let's know more about it go to screaming
from
now
from here download the tool on your
system
check various resources provided
on how to learn the tool from here
another alternative tool you can use for
auditing is
seo ability where you can enter the url
and get the audit reports
moving further with another free tool
which is
rf's backlink checker
gaining high quality backlinks is an
essential factor for seo ranking as it
shows the trust of other websites in
your content moreover it helps in
building the authority of your website
with the help of backlink checker you
get the data of all the websites linking
to your website rf's backlink checker
shows the data of top 100 backlinks
top 5 anchors
and top 5 pages
including
total number of backlinks and referring
domains in its free version
let's have a quick look at the tool
here let's take example of wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
wikipedia.com
now click on check backlink
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink checker
are sem rush backlink analytics tool and
seo ability
by signing up with these tools you will
get some free trials for your site last
but not the least let's know about the
mobile seo tool which is mobile friendly
test
studies show that in year 2020 60
percent of traffic was through mobile
devices
thus it is essential to keep your
website mobile friendly as well
here is when the mobile friendly test
comes into action
it helps to check if your website is
mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly test
and enter the url of your website
suppose i enter your www dot wikipedia
now click on test url
here you get the results
we can see that the page is mobile
friendly
to check more details you can navigate
to your search console account
well if you think we are done for today
then then keep watching this video as we
have two bonus tools for you
so here comes the first one
the serperator
search results vary with mobile devices
also your brand ranking may differ from
country to country
to get reports on this
circulator will be your all-time
companion it shows how search results
may differ for mobile devices or
locations
let's see how it works
go to circulator
now
let's fill in the required fields
now
let's select the location
let's run the live test
and here we get the results
that's it
daily you can run three free live tests
isn't this amazing
without taking a minute let's know about
the second bonus tool
which is
the rich results test
you must have seen these kinds of search
results on search pages
let's dive deep into it
yes these type of results are known as
rich results
to check whether your site is optimized
for rich results
go to rich results test
and add the url of your website
let's add the url of simplylearn
now click on test url
complete the verification
and check the report
so here we can see that
simply learns website
is eligible for google searches rich
results
to monitor rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console account
here we end the session i hope you got
the best knowledge about free seo tools
stay tuned with simply learn for more
such interesting videos
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and press the bell icon for more updates
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here